monsieur le préfet du haut rhin
messieurs les sénateurs mesdames et
messieurs député monsieur le président
de la région alsace sur président du
conseil départemental
jerry chers collègues notre territoire a
besoin des talents et de l'audace de
chaque alsacien pour se développer dans
la grande région et sur la scène
internationale à commencer par les élus
qui doivent être en première ligne mais
chaque collègue nous domaines de
compétences nous permet d'agir sur
l'humain sur l'emploi sur la vie
quotidienne des alsaciens et sur le
développement et l'attractivité des
territoires
mes chers collègues nos périmètres
d'action sur des bassins de vie à taille
humaine font des conseillers
départementaux avec les maires des
interlocuteurs privilégiés des habitants
des entreprises des associations
mes chers collègues c'est notre
enracinement sur les territoires et la
proximité avec nos concitoyens qui nous
ont permis de conquérir une légitimité
démocratique
cela nous confère une responsabilité
forte répondre au mieux aux attentes des
alsaciens
nos concitoyens attendent de nous des
actes l'idée de projet de fusion des
agences n'est pas nouvelle elle se
concrétise aujourd'hui avec la
possibilité d'écrire l'histoire de
l'alsace de construire un projet
ensemble
ce n'est pas toujours simple il faut
accepter que l'autre n'est pas toujours
la même vision que nous et que chacun
fasse un pas l'un vers l'autre pour
permettre de trouver des solutions
partagées
animé par un état d'esprit constructif
avec eric avec l'enfant des conseillers
départementaux
nous avons supporté le consensus en
action c'est ainsi qu'en l'espace de six
mois
nous avons lié
nos objectifs et nos visions dans un
cadre et sur des thématiques crucial
pour l'alsace que sont le tourisme et le
développement économique
ces six mois des changes entre le
haut-rhin le bas-rhin également avec la
région ce début de travail que nous
avons porté avec les agglomérations et
noro métropole nous permettent de faire
bloc et de poser les prémices d'une
alsace réunis autour d'objectifs communs
nous avons besoin qui fait la grande
région fasse rayonner nos territoires
avec elle en garantissant leur identité
et une attractivité nationale et
internationale nous avons besoin d'une
re métropole forte capitale européenne
mais qu'ils sachent aussi réconcilier le
rural et l'urbain
nous avons besoin de l'ensemble des
autres grands exact agglomérations et
intercommunalités mulhouse en tête pour
porter l'attractivité des bassins des
alsaciens nous avons besoin des forces
vives économiques et associatives pour
réinventer le mode d'action et de
partenariat et enfin surtout cette
dynamique doit être incarnée par les
alsaciens et pour les alsaciens nous
sommes sur une île qui n'est pas
partisane si ce n'est partisane de
l'intérêt général comme le disait adrien
zeller si nous fusionnons aujourd'hui
les agences c'est pour diminuer les
coûts mieux accompagner les acteurs
économiques favoriser l'emploi assurer
un développement équilibré l'alsace et
renforcer son attractivité
vous avez vu comme nous les résultats
les chiffres de l'emploi qui ne sont pas
bons est plus que jamais une nécessité
on a voulu couper les ailes des
départements auraient pu s'appuyer
s'apitoyer sur notre sort
mais nous avons décidé de nous
rassembler et de jouer collectif
nous avons ouvert d'autres chantiers de
travail en commun comme le repos
dominical
le bilinguisme
la culture ne travaillent au
rapprochement de nombreuses politiques
afin d améliorer et d'en diminuer les
coûts
nous voulons donc être innovant et
efficace pour construire l'alsace de
demain et c'est pour cette raison que
nous sommes aujourd'hui très heureux de
nous retrouver ensemble très heureux
avec eric de vous accueillir ici à
colmar pour ce moment très important